this is a production of Cornell
University
we're going to tell you about the study
we've been doing on behalf of USDA we
have a cooperative agreement with the
marketing service and they were really
interested in exploring what is the role
for USDA and supporting urban
agriculture and they recognized within
that that there is that there is this
sort of emerging interest philosophy a
huge interest right now look at the
country and how do we support and
cultivate urban farms peri-urban arms
there's a lot of people doing this so
what does it take for USDA to support
the growth and there's also also the
challenge of trying to understand is it
different or similar to how we're trying
to support farms in rural areas what are
the unique policy sort of political
issues that are facing these types of
producers and how do we nothing sort of
frame and redesign it himself to me
commercially and so that was where they
came to the small farm program they
asked could you help us do this study
because
and commercializing urban agriculture
they fully recognize and embrace the
fact that there's a tremendous amount of
urban agriculture happening to community
gardens and other types of structures
school gardens and all of those are
valued but what about the idea of trying
to make a living climbing another in
there what would that look like
where is it working where isn't it and
so what was interesting for us is that
you know we've been doing a lot of work
of this welfare program focused on
commercial heard of rural farms but for
us to is like probably extend our reach
and support the development of these
types of farms in urban areas so that's
kind of how we came so we had several
things that we wanted to be able to look
at first of all is klore in some of the
different factors that have helped
contribute to the success or different
challenge and earned urbanized
environment and what more policy
investments are community actions that
support the growth of these types of
farms when they were commercially viable
and then what would be sort of future
needs and ways at USDA in position and
support urban agriculture so one of the
interesting pieces here is that in urban
agriculture you have a sort of
convergence of urban planners and
activists really interested in issues of
food security issues of food deserts
that are all sort of clamoring to try to
figure out is there a place in a role
for urban farming in the system and so
this is all part of the context for why
so it was a one-year project and it's
been a whirlwind and it feels they was
over a hundred and fifty interviews and
that we focus in on 14 case farms and so
what we really wanted to do is serve and
help USDA think about the next farm bill
and so we're going to tell you the
Clinch of things that we find in the
work and then I'm sort of to tell you
about the next steps so one of the
issues around trying to define
commercial urban agriculture so many
difference in trying to find commercial
farming in general we use the cutoff of
having people earn at least $10,000 in
here from the sale of agricultural
products that we serve our baseline
that's what your tax exemption is based
on we had no real good way of doing that
but most of these farms to see have
diverse sources of diverse product mix
they go into diverse market channels so
they and their income from the sales of
a product is pretty sizable portion of
their overall farm manager and the first
job we faced was trying to identify
these fires and we were confident we
would find commercial urban farms but it
was actually really hard it was harder
than you would think primarily because
we wanted to have farms that have had a
few years of experience at least under
their belt three years and recently
they're just
so we wanted them to be established they
had to be willing to sort of talk with
us and share relation we had some
challenges getting people to trust us
but then we wanted also them to be able
to share with us some of their
financials so that we can really look at
a little bit more about what does it
look like to be farming and how do
people put together their whole package
and that's the one is geographic
diversity so the dark greens represent
the 14 cases that we actually did for 14
farms and so they go from east to west
and self we're not very well represented
in parts of the sort of southeast the
deep south but we did our best the
lighter green dots are farms that are
profiled in our study but they don't
want commercial farm or really
interesting new models and emerging
and so an amazing job of urban planning
background and so comes from this in a
from that perspective and so one of the
things that we wanted very much to do
with each of these cases is to really
really analyze the policy framework that
supports development event so included
in our study is and there's actually
other resources available but have
helped me pump uncover and sort of
create what we hope is more robust
database of policies that can help
communities supporter I'm going to give
you a little bit of a background and
then on the types of farms that we have
in the collection
there's 14 as I mentioned a split in the
gender of the farm manager so male and
female one of our important components
in our work is having racial diversity
represented in who we talk to and who
were the farm managers and we also
wanted to try to capture new Americans
who are farming in urban spaces and so
one of our farms is actually Burmese was
an American the years and businesses
from 3 to 23 years some of these folks
have been at this for a long time really
well established on average six years in
terms of thinking about farm development
we would consider all of these people
beginning farmers because USDA generally
recognizes individuals who have farmed
for more than 10 years is actually being
stable
so and several of these businesses are
at risk and in fact one of the cases and
probably making all that Salt's work out
that we just found out lost their life
so we'll talk a bit about what that
means for you know a commercial urban
park the acreage is of these farms range
from point 1 acre to 3 points we provide
very small and the tenure and their
ownership or access in that land is
continuous but many of these some own is
sometimes in combination of that a mix
of structures and we're going to talk a
little bit more about business structure
primarily because it has real
implications on income sources and the
actual business strategy so we have some
of these are LLC's and sort of similar
to many of the farms that we have in
rural areas we have some nonprofits and
some farms have split their activities
into the for-profit and nonprofit
entities the rate of revenue on these
marks ranged from 11,000 - I mean that's
wrong yeah it's gonna say yeah 12 to 1.5
million higher subliminal higher total
revenue from these parts so quite the
range of income and what we'll do is
sort of share with you sort of their
farming strategies and how that plays
out
so I
I might not use both microphones
laughter as long as you're at the podium
all right so I want to walk you guys
through three example times just can I
show you the breadth and diversity of
the types of box that we were
interviewing so Karen fresh garden is
the farm that Ani mentioned late late -
who is the farmer is a Burmese refugee
she's been in the country for about
eight years now and she was farming when
she was back in Burma and when she came
to the States
she enrolled in a program called new
roots for Refugees it's run by a group
called cultivate Kansas City and they do
a lot to increase the amount of local
food in the Kansas City area but they do
help with this farmer training program
that assists new Americans in refining
their skills building markets and
becoming commercial parts in order to
have their own businesses their own
income to increase their opportunity
so lay two thumbs she farts on her own
land where her house is - it's just a
half acre in her backyard and she grows
a little bit of everything she grows
what she calls American crops and
Burmese crops and she sells them in two
different markets but her primary
markets are at farmer's markets she's a
two in Kansas City and she is kind of
lucky in Kansas City Kansas because
there aren't any policies restricting
urban farming at the moment for
improving it without matter but she's
able to operate as she needs to but she
did get an NRCS equip grant that helps
her get a high channel where she put up
at the end of last year which she said
has improved her production or immensely
so the important thing to know about
Leigh - and a few other people like her
is that not only is their farm important
for having a commercial business but
it's also very important for food
security for the household and she says
the best thing about farming in the city
is that we have our own vegetables and
did not have to buy them with the people
that she serves at market so that's one
example very small small business second
one I think a lot of folks in the room
now is Brooklyn range there in Brooklyn
and Queens New York they were founded in
2008 by group of five people who wanted
to experiment with growing food on
rooftops they have managed to get to
sites like I said one in Queens one in
Brooklyn and that they have a ten year
and a twenty year in B switch Ben
planner who's on the head farmer one of
the co-founders said is extremely
important because he would not think
about farming on a rooftop or anywhere
if he had less than a ten year lease
because the amount of work and resources
to go into it they are specializing in
salad greens and other things in a quick
succession crops that can be sold for a
high value they're growing microgreens
all year round and have sales on the
around as a result and not only are they
doing restaurant sales but they're doing
a lot of other additional activities
they're hosting weddings they're hosting
big farm dinners and they've gotten a
lot of support too not just from doing
those other activities but from other
grants and seeing programs that have
helped them get the resources to farm on
the route because as you can imagine
it's not cheap to blow all that soil up
onto a roof but they're doing it they
would like more help of distribution and
to find increasingly more favorable
lease terms to keep these businesses
alive and they are cognizant of the fact
that they are not feeding the city
they're specializing in high-value crops
that are only going to white tablecloth
restaurants but that they say does not
mean there is an impact because they're
doing all these other things that they
hope are improving
they also using pine pinus they do yep
and we're going to talk a little bit
about that season extension has impacted
the third one on the total flipside from
Karen fresh Gardens it is green city
growers in Cleveland Ohio
it's a 3.25 greenhouse that uses a
hydroponic floating rats to grow about
they said last year a lot but they they
own the land that they're on they got
help owning the land that they're on
through the city of Cleveland Cuyahoga
County they got new market tax credits
but most farms can't get but if you and
if you want about new market tax credits
let's have a different seminar probably
will get any news people over because
it's not that interesting but they are
it is a way that controlled environment
agriculture farms have been able to
build out in cities and it's not
available to soil based farms because
farms are excluded from new market tax
credits but it's a way that people who
want you to develop buildings can can
actually get financing so that helped
them to build out their seventy million
dollar facility they're employing thirty
six people and they are a cooperative
while Evergreen cooperatives who founded
green city brewers is a non-profit
they have three separate cooperative
businesses that they've started in a
low-income area of Cleveland in order to
provide a suite of resources to
employees who come from those
neighborhoods to kindly lift them up out
of the poverty that surrounds these
facilities so there is a program that
helps them secure housing and own a home
in the neighborhood there's a program
that helps them own a car so they can
get to work trying to make all of the
things possible to get these people to
work while growing a lot of butterhead
lettuce
now there's no actual return yet as a
co-owner but the aspirations within 10
years they will
able to do
so obviously they're different and it
was a challenge for us to figure out how
to present them how to parse this very
small data set that has a lot of
diversity but these are just some of the
examples of how diverse it is per square
foot they are earning farm sales between
14 cents per square foot and $12 63
cents so that's a huge range and there
are those that are focusing on specialty
crops like I said microgreens routes
mushrooms and there's also a diversity
of farming experience and that might
have an effect on how much they're able
to field and we're going to talk through
audience web talk through a little bit
of how this plays out in terms of their
finances and a couple of slides but the
farm product sales for these
organizations is farm some of them our
organizations are anywhere between nine
and 100 percent of their total revenue
so we'll see where that other or those
other parts of the revenue come from but
it's worth noting that there's a lot of
diversity and a lot of them aren't
relying solely on what they're selling
in order to keep themselves in business
and ten of the 14 farms earned a profit
three are nominal profit farms but we
included them in this study of
commercial urban agriculture for reasons
that will explain a couple of slides I'm
going to just to give you an overview of
what this looks like
we separated the farms into three
categories just to kind of wrap our
heads around the data so like I said
there's some nonprofits there's some for
profits that people are doing all
different types of things so she kind of
make it simple we separated them into
program focused farms which are those
farms kind of like green city growers
where they're trying to provide more
than just food there is some sort of
social component of their work some sort
of program and often their nonprofit or
they have a non-profit arm that enables
them to get grant money and individual
giving in order to support the
programmatic work and as you can see
that makes up over half of what they
earn on average there's diversified farm
so farms kind of like Brooklyn Grange
that are growing food for people to eat
but they're also doing a lot of other
things like workshops and events and
that ends up making a significant
portion on average of their total or
revenues and then those production
focused farms which as the name suggests
focus on production and they might have
a few activities that happen but those
are more kind of one-off events that
occur and so just looking at this these
programs focus diversify the production
focused farms you don't really get a
sense of what that means in terms of
scale in terms of how much they're
earning and so we try to break it down
in different ways looking at the ranges
of income and I'm just gonna walk you
through a little bit of that information
so you can see what this looks like in
practice
so we're going to focus primarily in on
income and sales and profit and we have
aggregated the data to sort of protect
the information from these farms and so
what I want to be able to share with you
just sort of a breakdown about total
income and this is a little bit of what
mallya share on that previous life okay
where we have arranged maximum anywhere
from I think around forty three thousand
at the bottom all the way up to one
point two point three million for total
income but we cut off the chart at a
hundred thousand or one millionaire
photographer and so the total income of
wire largest operation was 3.3 when you
combine both what they're making from
agriculture tools what they're getting
from grips can't give sprints and other
activities so what's really important to
note is of course what's really obvious
the production focus farms where a small
total income to the farm very little
done with additional activities but also
the majority of that earnings coming
from agriculture when we look at the
diversified farms and the farms that our
program focus the ones that are using a
lot of
additional activities to supplement what
they're doing our difference is in the
actual earnings by bag sales is not that
different but what this does allow that
those farms to do is actually to
supplement income to provide effective
longer-term employment for many of the
individuals that are working on the
operations
so when we take it then and we add to
this and so these are ranges so these
these choirs are just representing
ranges to give you a sense we're still
trying to figure out how you actually
want to represent this for us da so so
these fires are basically the top and
the bottom of our range for a group of
farms that are included here and so in
this business strategy what's
interesting here is at the very bottom
and you actually look at the orange bars
which represent the agriculture based
sales the income from sales and then the
actual profit that they declared after
you remove expenses when you look at
those yellow the yellow bars at the
bottom you can find there's very very
low profitability in those ones that are
program based these farms are doing a
lot of things they may have really huge
incomes but at the end of the day the
total profits from those operations are
not that much different from the very
small production
so this was a bit counterintuitive for
us and so we're still sitting with this
because it is actually kind of
surprising to think about that and what
you're not seeing in here is that you
know these are all parts at different
sizes with different production capacity
and one of the other challenges in
working with small farms whether they're
rural or urban or any kind of small
business but especially if it's a sole
proprietor is how does the actual owner
operator ticket draw from the business
and so some of our firms actually do
have to pay the owner operator the
primary manager from the actual sales of
products if others don't they just take
what's profitable what's leftover and so
that is a really difficult place in as
far as trying to manage and analyze this
type of information so we recognize that
and again there's also the additional
drop of food that's supporting food
security of the household how do you
actually account for that impact on a
household income so those are sort of
future research questions additional
types of inquiry that have to happen but
we're being out of our scope but in
trying to think about the strategy that
the business strategy that these
different operations is what's really
evident is that and even though they had
really high operating budget these
program patients who are not actually
that much
and very small farms they were primarily
earning from the Salamanca problems so
one thing that we tried to do is because
again there's a range of size we tried
to sort of represent this in a way to
help us sort of get our heads around
some of this information of earnings and
profit and cost and so we use a small
area point one acre and it's a funny
thing to use it because when you scale
up if you want to represent things on an
acreage basis that's really common in
our work and rural agriculture but that
scale up is fraught with so many errors
and doesn't really represent sort of the
intensity of production in these farm
systems so we actually scaled everything
to attend the matter because that
instead of the Madison unit that it
really I think represents the intensity
of the way these people are doing and
managing their businesses so and it
provides certain way of comparing across
these different categories and we're
going to use this same metric of a tenth
of an acre to look at a bunch of
different things about these farms so
when you look at just a tenth of an acre
and you look at the serve egg sales all
of a sudden we're looking at a really
different framework between these
different types of approaches where are
one of our farms is farming a very small
scale is making $55,000 as far as their
top end from a ten
um and and if you look at that
production book it's the first set of
bars at the far end in fact the total
profit for that temp today is higher
than those other part that had much
higher operating budgets so um with
embedded within this is a controlled
environment farm and so that has you
know the ability to party around and it
has a much higher earning so that's kind
of lost in this and so we want to
recognize that but if you really just
look at the tenth of the nacre over a
whole year annual sales the very small
farms don't look at that bad
one of the key factors in affecting this
that is actually quite dramatic isn't
use of season extension and so many of
these farms and I think Molly will
probably share more about this use high
tunnels and they've benefited from an
NRCS program in which producer can get
the cost of a high tunnel page as long
as they report yield data from that time
and many of these firms that are growing
outdoors with season extension are using
high tunnels and if you actually focus
in on that middle section you can see
that their earnings and their overall
profit per tenth of an acre is higher
then those that are using the controlled
environment agriculture so the ability
to farm really intensively using the
soil based media here based on this our
study of the sort of information that we
have for those particular farms when
they have that season extension it
really did a lot to enhance security at
the farm to manage risk for the farm by
increasing the months of production but
also then the total output in the value
of that collection the range of the
firms are as far as a tenth of an acre
that's like the orange is anywhere from
forty seven forty to seventy four is
their total sales but then the
profitability is much lower I'll attempt
an acre
okay so one of the again it's difficult
again we're trying to sort of give you a
couple of different lenses to look at
this it doesn't show you the scale the
months outdoors that people are
producing are varies based on the reason
you saw this sort of range as far as we
have to the east coast to the west coast
in the south so some people just out
that they can grow outdoors and it's
it's easier to do it even our firms in
the South they're using some a bit of
high tunnels it's a really tremendous
program that probably has had more
impact on those operations and any other
intervention but it's coming from us
and then another issue that this does
mask of it is the diversity of the crops
that are being grown on these farms and
so that is actually sort of the next
ones that we want to sort of give you a
sense of and so one of the things that
we found is that those farms that were
actually grown on and there's a new care
a new category merit we're calling it
specialized those are the farms that are
earning more than half of their total
income from the sale of one by most of
the times these farms are growing things
like microgreens or sow degrees and in
the farms that were able to specialize
actually have higher profitability and
this is actually kind of important
especially in terms of thinking about
the overall food security and the sort
of impact on community that these farms
could have because if they're having to
be profitable they're narrowing the
number of crops that grow a salad does
not a full value make and it's a
challenge it's the challenge of building
a profitable business what do you make
on a square foot basis what can you earn
where you have a consistent marketplace
where do you take advantage of your
resources those farms that were
intensively producing fewer crops and
those specialty high-value crops for our
specialty markets were the ones that
were actually
to demonstrate a more profitable
business so they're ones that were
non-specialized those farms are growing
their diversity of crops often using a
CSA or some other type of a marketing
channel at farmer's markets but again
they were having to search for balance a
broad number of crops that they were
able to provide to their customers in
contrast to those that are specializing
and then so we can start talking about
what is this market channels that these
different firms are using and there are
the same ones that we even see urban
farmers use or rural farmers using
farmers markets CSAs how does everyone
know the term CSA is Implanon a
Community Supported Agriculture I see
shapes yes okay um so very common in
from many small farms in rural areas and
for these firms as well but you go in
for CSA frankly is a lot to ask for a
small scale for a very small footprint
because you have to offer a diverse
number of crops and so you're moving
away from that specialization and your
ability to plan and use your space most
efficiently
there's always crops that don't make
anybody
you're going for a CSA and so those
farms were not earning or profiting as
much as the other firms and the farmers
market you're capturing all of that
directly tell funds but those books you
are using direct wholesale to
restaurants and other types of purveyors
directly sawing at wholesale they're
they're our kit of course they were
probably more specialized and what they
were growing but they didn't do too bad
as far as being more profitable than
certainly the CSA farm but it's still
challenging to them because they have to
specialize in the profitability it's not
necessarily always there but so but the
markets and again I always want to sort
of advocate that for many of these farms
they're not paying the learners that
Vegas salary so that makes it
challenging and if you look at sort of
comparing just about different owners
taking a draw versus not on the other
side the owners are actually paid as
part of the expansions of the farm and
then closer to me they're not being paid
but they're taking basically the profit
from the farm or other things from the
department support the household in the
family now I can have other jobs off of
the farm so there's a
family um so there's a wide range and
there's a some whites there so basically
a fairly wide range of total income per
month in on a point one acre basis but
you can see that the sort of bars right
now as far as the upper burnings for
those that are being paid that's that
money it's really building for them but
it's there's just not a good way to
separate it out we do have information
in our collection of and based on labor
hours and total labor hours so that's
one of the things we're trying to
analyze is paid labor almost all these
firms use unpaid labor through
volunteers and we know that's fraught
with a lot of challenge because it's not
actually I think of labor labor category
in most cases and so we're really trying
to work on these issues related to
volunteer labor on that in farms whether
urban or rural so it just gives you an
overview and a sense of the sort of
types of farms that we're seeing I think
the real take-home message is that these
highly specialized farms that are
growing in soil can be quite profitable
and competitive in their areas if they
have season extension technologies that
they're using and that the word in some
ways is still out about controlling
weather and
[ __ ] terms relative to the final
sort of profitability but with the
caveat we you know we're not completely
comparing apples to apples here because
of the way people are representing their
own salary Karl this is the challenge
across small farms everywhere
so it's a lot of different ways to look
at data and I figured it'd be helpful we
actually applied those lenses to the
fireplace as you guys do so Karen quest
part number is the refugee farmer cheese
production focus she does very few other
activities and she had received that
equipped grant that allowed her to get
the high tunnel that she implemented at
the end of last year but that did not
actually figure into her sales for 2015
she's really get up and running in
cooking anywhere so she doesn't actually
fit that season extension category and
like I said she's non-specialized she's
growing a wide variety of things and
she's proud of that um and it her income
for those I think that there were seven
I know there was seven productions but
this part was around the middle in terms
of her yield pretend Baker
she sells for eight months of the year
at the two farmers markets that she
sells through another four primary
deserve her only actually market
channels in 2015 and she has no paid
labor does not pay their sought the
salary but her family helps out and her
her family members also have off farm
jobs so together they are supporting the
household as is some of the yield for
the farm but she and every other farmer
that I
opportunity to speak to over the past
year did not figure how much she was
taking so hard to be able to put dollar
value on that she pays herself in the
profits like I am suggested and she is
an excellent record keeper when it comes
to her production but not when it comes
to her finances and she gets a lot of
assistance actually through the training
program that she worked with for four
years and then graduate after girl mark
the new roads for Refugees program so
she wants to improve her ability to
manage her own finances but that's
predicated on her English language
acquisition which she is not totally on
board with committing herself to for a
lot of reasons including the amount of
time that she has including the fact
that she wants to diversify our markets
and start sign restaurants because she
sees that there's more potential for her
to be earning more money potentially she
works
Brooklyn Grange is it one of those
diversified farms we talked about like I
said they have a lot of other things
that they do about half of their income
comes from non production related
activities they have high sales because
they're specializing in microgreens and
salad greens edible flowers and they
have two high tunnels on their farm in
Brooklyn one hydro moment farming in
Queens and they are heating them
throughout the winter to grow those
metric means they do have 12 months of
sales a year and they pay all their
employees that used to have volunteers
as kind of a community outreach
opportunity but they realize that it was
costing them too much money to have
volunteers they were better off painting
people who are skilled in their labor to
do their work so they have 12 full-time
year-round employees and other 12
part-time seasonal employees and they
are continuing to refine their crops
they do very intensive record-keeping to
figure out what's making money and
what's maybe money and what's not per
square foot and they're also scaling up
their events they are aiming to do 10
weddings in 2016 and I have
company wasn't mine so green city
growers is controlled environment
agriculture obviously but they are
program focused like I covered before
and way they are supporting their
employees and half of their total income
is coming from their sales and 2015 and
they're continuing to scale that up but
the other half is coming from Grants and
they also have significant loans that
are not operating loans but just as kind
to keep in the back of your head this
was a cheap thing to start out there
doing all direct wholesale they're
selling to major grocery store chains in
the near Midwest region and want to call
Ohio the Midwest but the near Midwest
and everyone is getting paid they the
starting salary of the starting wage for
a worker at green city growers is $10
now become members of the co-operative
their pay increases and their big
problem right now is building out of
more markets they built this facility
and they say this themselves they built
this facility and thought they will come
they will buy our lettuce they are near
to about 14 major institutions hospitals
colleges museums and they figured this
would be an easy sell what they didn't
realize is that a lot of those
institutional customers don't use head
lettuce they want to pre-cut lettuce
and I said now that that probably would
have been something that they should
have investigated but they're very open
like that it's just worth noting to you
this is the only major large scale
indoor growing operation either with in
greenhouses or a totally closed system
with no lights and only using LED
lighting that was willing to be a part
of our study a lot of those types of
larger businesses have great
front-facing public relations but
they're not really willing at this point
to share information about their sales
because it ends about their technology
because their trade secrets in this very
information industry so that's just what
those financial findings look like a win
at the farms and I want to talk you
through a couple of other findings as
well so the farmers are largely
self-taught it's surprising how many
farmers say you know four years ago I
didn't know anything about farming and
people don't use it if they're dentists
that way but they but farmers I guess
there's a little bit more leeway but
they're working on small-scale so maybe
there's a better opportunity to learn
more on small-scale and they really want
help building out their skills they
recognize that they don't have a lot and
there is a call for having Extension
agents in urban areas that aren't in a
lot of the places that we visited and
they're lucky because overall their
support from the community is high there
is sometimes tension monies when these
farmers come in and we're going to talk
a little bit about that tension but
overall the community support is high
even if
and legal support is not high because
agriculture is not accepted use in most
cities only in one of the cities that we
profiled a farm in was agriculture
already on the books and that was in
Kansas and the farmers if they had a
policy recommendation I think would
probably be similar to most farmers and
it is ways to reduce their costs and
they have high pots high utility costs
high land costs and they've benefited
like we said from programs like the NRCS
equip program that helps them get high
towns and they want to see more like
that so just to walk you through a few
of our preliminary findings and immunity
this quickly
um land access is an issue as you can
imagine it's hard to find land in the
city to do farming especially land that
does not have a toxic history or you can
even find the history on
and as uncovered before and as I said a
little bit about they're using their
findings they are comfortable when they
focus on Miche produce and not the whole
CSA calorie crop production strategy the
cost of social entrepreneurship are high
that's all of the things that you do
that aren't farming the carrot city
taking kids on tours and having a
workshop on beachy veins those are
things that people are often doing for
free and they're a great community
outreach tool especially if they're
trying to build knowledge of where food
comes from for people who don't have
access to farmers but that means that
they're not farming and when they're not
farming they're not making money water
costs in particular are still very high
for farmers when they really need that
water and they're often paying sewage
fees and stormwater fees which are extra
on top of just the irrigation water
costs and then finally commercial urban
farms are primarily owned by white
people who are are farming regardless of
where they are with a community of color
or their inner white community those are
usually the people who are doing the
commercial farming there are other sorts
of farmers that happen in the city but
for commercial purposes it's one of the
reasons what we had a lot of difficulty
getting a diversity in terms of ethnic
background and racial diversity and
socio-economic diversity because it
requires we're finding certain things or
to get your land so I'm going to skip
over the land access pieces we're
running out of time but I'm happy to
talk more about how zoning has been
affected the one thing I will mention
little city gardens which is up here is
the one farm that we profiled that has
lost their land since we started this
process and they are out at the end of
the year and is going to be developed it
is one of the last significant green
spaces over 1/2 acre in San Francisco
and it is now going to be a school I
went head over to honor talk a little
bit about the racial so one thing that's
really apparent in the urban egg space
is the real tension around racial and
structural racism that played out in
every single one of the cities and
places we work and it's not the kind of
thing and we talk about very often in
rural places because everyone there is
primarily white but what has played out
of many of these cities and is that
[ __ ] the african-american community is
not only trying to farm they're also
trying to affect that health and
well-being of their communities often
lower resource and impoverished
communities and they are systematically
and specifically not able to access plan
it's actually really deeply disturbing
and one of the issues that we confronted
ourselves and trying to visit and talk
to some of these facts and bits you know
viable farm businesses but they're like
what difference is this going to make us
to talk to you and I think it's out one
of those places of sensitivity everybody
has a social mission in mind but one of
the fire one of the one of our advocates
here in the New York City itself here in
Washington she is just she just said you
know if you really want to help us just
ask us what we want
we want ask us come into the community
ask us what we need to support the
development of our clients and I think
it's something that is actually the
center of the next step of this project
is really how do we create honest
conversation around this stuff and work
with planners policymakers and
developers who don't have the language
in order to communicate and I think what
we're going to do is just we this other
piece it's ties to this is social
entrepreneurship and I just want to take
a moment to talk about this with you
because um we a lot of the farms six of
the 14 have specific educational
activities that they're doing and they
are they really recognize you know the
but here you have this bar in this urban
area and all of these people have no
idea where their food comes from it is
part of our mission to sort of change
that and actively to help bring schools
and get kids familiar with how do you
grow staff and parents so they
understand the value of Agriculture and
so it's a service that they're providing
and it is an unpaved surface for the
most part all of agriculture benefits
from this activity but yet it's urban
firms on their own they're sort of Seoul
Korea and whether it's a community
garden or an actual commercial operation
that's doing it so what does that mean
for all of Agriculture
this is a question Island where our
partnerships with urban farms like
is actually able to facilitate greater
awareness it benefits all of agriculture
not just those few little farms in this
month so it is a contextual thing how do
we build this out and so we know that
these cases the whole point of the study
has been to really try to elevate
examples where people are making livings
are trying to be commercial on a very
small space well it's just challenging
by the footprint but it's challenged by
all of these other socio-economic and
cultural things going on around them but
I feel like we have found some really
exciting stories and what's really
interesting to me is that the story that
these farms are telling when they're
really focused on throwing food and
growing it in a good way it's not that
different than what we see in a place so
many of these farms are really hungry to
interact with their world colleagues to
be learning the best strategies to be
participating those types of training
programs to be doing the hard work of
capturing their costs in a more active
way um and they recognize that you know
here I'm growing lettuce or I'm growing
microgreens none of this it's dealing
with the real food insecurity issues at
my community faces but I'm gonna do a
business
so but in the end it's being there and
being in that place of doing agriculture
that has a huge impact on their
communities and what we need are some
ways in which we can actually quantify
that time you actually quantify a change
in the land values of a community
because of our farmers come in there and
take your place and actually expected
all sorts of things neighborhood
activity how do you put a price tag when
there's people trying right now to sort
of understand what what are you measure
itself don't like how you turn it into a
number that we can use to sort of assess
of the actual broader impact of these
types of activities so I think that's as
far as future research one of the things
that we're recommending to USDA is to
sort of think about other investing in
these types of metrics and coming up
with other ways to compliment and
classic economic basis for which we
evaluate this
so we're going to be taking this study
on USDA once we're finished with our
work we've been working living with the
14 advisors from around the country
people that are real experts in deeply
vested in or urban agriculture we've
been working with us to sort of think
about how do we tell the story because
it has certain fairly broad reaching
possibly impacts particularly for
planners and individuals that are
sitting in that role in city and urban
governance so what we want to do is once
we're done with this part of it in this
in this work is published is that we
will be doing the regional presentations
at this and cultivating in front of more
regional dialogue and conversations with
planners as well as those activists
leading to a national community of
practice that's really focused on the
partner so that's the activities for the
next year is to sort of bring together
those people that are either farming
themselves are currently committed to
trying to figure out how can you make
urban farms more successful and then how
do we connect that to other individuals
that are trying to really think about
those broader social impacts of the farm
bill and think about what what
particular changes in USDA legislation
how do we be correct or changed the
authority of the world
arm of USDA so to be the world and urban
AG development sometimes it's just
changing the word of dropping the word
that allows about grants and funds to be
used in deployed in urban areas so
that's one of our attentions because of
what mommy said that they're very few
controlled environment act operations
are fully contained and no vertical
parts were included this completely
contained building phase where we are
working right now with the association
of vertical apartment Amil and a couple
of others to try to actually add more
cases based on that
to watch this out and then ultimately we
want to be able to build a deeper egg
urban egg resource library to help
planners as well as farmers finding
resources and connections often these
folks up you know they are hunting in
technique just like everybody else on
the internet and it's not
so how do you actually distill urban AG
policy if you want to write an urban egg
policy for a heavy livestock who's done
the best job of considering the issues
so we want to be able to take all of
that and distill it into a place that
can service our resources
I maybe maintain work with our
colleagues to do that
they're never going to make a very big
thing and I think not that is not and
yet there's so much there packages with
individual awareness and
I think that's good value in this paper
but it is kind of it's it creates a
split personality for an urban farm
because they're supposed to be walking
or addressing Mike absolutely with me
right now saying that's all we are about
but the mines are not producing any
things that makes any market their
community if they really want to farm so
can we talk about it but what it really
is and then think about the
complementary activities
and just for example there's one farm in
Philadelphia
CSA farm boxes program that there are
farm but none of the clue that that is
going to that are boxes from it's coming
from the big farms in New Jersey and
Lancaster and everywhere else so that
they can check a regional approach and
introduce people to the concept of
regional aggregate ruin urban farm and
that actually is interesting programs in
New York City working with senior
centers now which they're doing say box
type models they are farming on rooftops
they're getting exercise they're having
those activities there's complimentary
farms that are making money that are
actually trying to make a living but
we're not asking one operation we don't
ask for earth world farms to should meet
all of these social goals while I can we
allow urban farms to question that
furthermore it's like this treated
business overview I mean what you're
saying is they're primarily
profitability motivated like we'd like
to think every farmer should be right
why should they get any subsidies why
should we keep developing any education
resources if they were coming in to
build refugee communities your ways of
freedom people up and that's something
we would all invest and I think as a way
to sort of grow our next generation
population so yeah I feel like they're
asking for your additional things you
know there should be a really clear it's
a very clear social mission that can be
funded and supported with outcomes that
are related to education training or
other things that's one sort of type of
operation and so Brooklyn Marines for
example they split that off they
recognize that that takes so much energy
and a bunch of its own
if I split you don't allow them actually
get back to the business of the business
but not lose sight of the opportunity
presented by being Primus and that's the
elegant design that
it's examples like that there's
something all sorts of examples like
that that you don't think about and I
think it's really easy for us to
consider and really focus in on an urban
specific community but really these are
farms that are not
there is some of them that feel like
they are that they lose vegetables to
two-legged predators but not so they
really are trying to make a living so
we're running way over time I'm going to
suggest it for anyone who would like to
check with Anu and Molly
they will presumably stay in front for a
few minutes
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu